Two members of the cast of Little House in the Prairie
was in Tulsa this weekend,
and we just had the best time.
I've been working for Dean Butler for a little over a year.
I am his social media director,
and then I just help coordinate things as needed.
I live in Tulsa, so having Dean and Jennifer Ginotti,
who played Baby Rose, come to Tulsa this weekend was so much fun.
Aside from the events that we had scheduled,
we also did some fun things like baking cookies,
painting pumpkins,
and doing some press for the events that were on the schedule.
This was a new experience for me,
cause I'd never been in a new studio before.
Being part of Little House has really opened so many doors for me
and so many new experiences that I didn't even know were possible.
It's really incredible to see,
50 years later,
how much people are still so obsessed with Little House on the Prairie
and really care about this legacy.
The Little House cast is truly like family,
and it is so special to have a small part in it all.
While there's not any other events for the entire cast on the schedule
this year, Dean does have a lot of book signings coming up,
and there's a lot to look forward in 2025.
Little House is just getting started.